welcome Jim promoting a you're doing a
residency at the Paramount in Long
Island which is a great great theater
right I've only done once I'm doing it
again in February I've only did it one
time and have you ever done a residency
before were you [ __ ] the same place
for a month no no I'm not I'm not gonna
lie I'm I'm excited I'm a little worried
why I'm not Billy Joel I'm not um you
know so do I have a great following low
knowledge yeah am I worried about the
shows
no I'm I know I'm gonna pull off a
different show every single time dying
to do is forever and ever since like
shoes I played the Paramount and you've
been on shows we go this [ __ ] row
yeah yeah it's great that one I
immediately went I'm gonna film a
special here then after I film the
special one I want to do a residency
here and then I remember talking whoever
and took two three years before it made
it to them and they were like oh my god
would love to do that so you know my
only worry is I just hope people come
out how long is the residency well
tickets are on self form for three for
now we'll say three Jimbo but three
shows or three months three months okay
now it's one it's one Saturday a month
oh it's not every weekend no okay no no
it's once a month one show a month well
that's great yes so it's playing which
is the same thing Billy Joel's doing at
the garden right exactly yeah
he plays once a month I say and I Drive
home at night yeah I'm gonna paint for
hotel Oh
to be able to do this like that to have
a theater that you want to do a
residency and that's also like right by
your house yes and then is we got
production I guess is a little more than
just walking out doing stand-up on this
one kanae yeah just lift your mic these
mics that poor Jim is trying to fix his
mic and make this thing keeps falling
this really stinks this mic going on
here hammer good yeah so is this
stand-up or music or both or it's first
stand-up we're gonna come out I don't
know how long the stand-ups gonna be it
could be I've three act
first is all gonna be stand up seconds
all gonna be story tone the end is gonna
be a characters sketch and music improv
[ __ ] so how long is the show hour and a
half okay
with videos of videos or sketches that
are segues to go into it so it's a show
it's a shower brats awesome they're
dropping cash for production to drop and
can't there it is yeah your your thing
about doing the the storytelling but
your stories are always funny anyway
like you I think you're the best
storyteller I've ever seen well I you
know I learned a lot of it from coming
on here you know back in the day how far
back you guys know so that was and I
learned that that's a major part of what
I do so the storytelling can go in these
nights some of them are really fun oh
yeah I got to keep funny but some of
them can go a little deeper and far
further and wider than an average like
oh here's a here's what I met osseous
call you're gonna get quite a chuckle
out of this some of them I may go a
little deeper into it but always end
with a Whittle laughs I guess I
understood that it's storytelling that's
when like you don't have to have a
punchline every 30 seconds right that is
the magic Sam right when you're a little
more serious they're like oh whoa I'm
actually gonna listen to this no I can
listen like a mood music playing behind
and the lighting is different so it's
it's almost like the middle part is the
one-man theater show sure and then
hopefully that'll turn into something
and then the end is here's Ozzy priest
and Metallica sing and bingo come on
let's do this it's also great because
now it's like anybody that goes to these
shows is gonna be like huh he can do
that show or he can do that show where
you can do that surely that's the magic
whatever the next move is but how do you
follow the stand-up your stand-up is so
strong what do you take a break or do
you just go right into something or do
you tell them the breaks are gonna be
video they're gonna be 2 to 4 minute
videos someone are gonna be there
they're mostly gonna be pre
film sketches but that's a war I'm gonna
have a guy in between but most likely
it's gonna be big loud sketches playing
on the side are you worried about coming
out after that like will people stay
well that like are you have you done
this before now but I know I've done
every part of what I'm gonna do
I've done the stand-up I did the story
talented the rock [ __ ] so and people
stay for all of it so I ain't worried
about yeah that's so cool though that
you're able to figure out something
where you're like okay I've amassed this
body of work right so what do I do next
that kind of encapsulates everything you
heard all into one sugar wine I'm trying
to figure out a one-man show which I I
am working on but boom I can do part of
it every month here at the Paramount
right you know you got you're still in a
city Jimbo I don't know if you're the
city or Jersey yeah you probably do I
don't know last night I popped in to uh
what's the cellar not the cellar but
they get these other rooms the cellars
the only one I really do the Comedy
Cellar well what's the damn another room
that's it Village Underground yeah
that's amazing
that's amazing it was sick I walked in I
was very intimidated because I've been
out of that I've been out of that system
for a long time you know like anyone do
guests it when I don't watch Neal
Brennan go up and I watch these guys go
up and do it you sure went ah [ __ ] it
let me let me give it a whack I felt
like 94 Brewer at the comic strip yeah
on a Friday following Ray Romano and
Wanda Sykes I was where I went off on a
cuff and it was it was amazing I haven't
had that opportunity in a long time
yeah really well yeah this is no one I
want to go on after less than Brewer no
noise
Jim kill is harder but but but it's
really funny and like and no one's ever
seen your stand-up the stories you tell
like it's it they're really good they're
really well put together and they're
extremely funny I've never seen anybody
do it as well as you I mean it
well thanks Jimbo and then hopefully you
know they'll really resonate with so
many 's with so many shows so no no I'm
psyched like I said I don't know you
know today we talked with the production
they're out of Nashville too like oh
we've done Motley Crue or listen Alan
was so my imagination I can't even keep
up what they're throwing on the table
like at the end what if we do explosives
and like we can't do explosives fog and
laser lights fog and light now you gotta
be discipline though right now that you
know that like you've got all the
options of this company plus the venue's
gonna let you do whatever you want cuz
it's not one choice three shows like
there's a lot of tickets exactly you're
gonna be allowed to do whatever you want
but you have to be disciplined to not
just be like let's do right and and I am
I'm I'm Tate I'm went in going alright
here's the stories here's the stand-up
and the stamps are gonna be bits you
know topical I have a different view
than most others and and a lot of Long
Island stuff too so right I'm have to up
man you are and tickets are on sale at
the Jim Breuer residency at the
Paramount it's an amazing theater
official Jim Breuer dot-com or Jim
Breuer on Twitter it's BRE you ER you're
also doing other gigs now a funny bone
in Albany Performing Arts Center this
Friday in our Englewood New Jersey and
are you doing Illinois and the Rialto
Theatre in Tucson in December which is
amazing 28th and then I you be New
Year's Eve you're gonna be at the improv
in Tempe which is in other great room so
you're smart you're just a dumb [ __ ] I'm
doing Chicago this Friday like you're
going to like Arizona which is where you
should be in the Emirates we're bringing
my kids pretty yes go out there stay in
the Sun we're in the mountains we're
driving I'm staying out there for like
10 days oh you are you making soon as
Christmas over on a plane where out of
here
and then spend it like 10 days yes we
set up the stupid tree last night
I'm telling you two years I'm gonna
start drawing a [ __ ] and you're tired
of it
look here we go we're drawing it and
putting a painting up on a we're gonna
put a little notebook panning of the
tree on the side of the wall boom we're
done that's a pop-up the lights are in
it once the kids are once they know
what's going on why you gifts it's over
yeah it's over what do you know the 23rd
I'm buying it it's over
you get excited about nothing's going on
both of your parents are dead both your
parents are dead yeah how has that been
for your for your family and for you you
know it was such a big part of you my
dad was well my mom was too but um you
know my dad I
I missed horrendously I still miss him
my mom was this whole other beast she's
I was like oh [ __ ] I'm out of here
why you strike she was and I don't mean
that in a mean way but she was blind
almost fully blind her much couldn't
chew anymore
it was it was gonna sear and [ __ ] it was
a disaster I'm like oh my god it's time
to go
I believe you know it's old yellowish
a91 yeah she's gonna be nice I don't
think we're gonna call you mean you're
probably the most dutiful son yeah as
far as what you did for your mom and dad
I mean you are in a very dutiful son I
mean you're far better son than I am
yeah but I it's um we kind of grew up in
the same I can't say that I can't speak
to worry you grew up but I grew up that
you know my dad was in he grew up with
temperance this is like a [ __ ] old
movies timber oysters he should eat
possum if they can catch it turtles and
like what turtles possums I don't know
he catch a turtle and roaming apart and
there was a ton of us from his mom was
dead by the time he was 3 and then he
was in World War 2
for 3 years his whole family's 5
brothers all 5 want to fight for years
all five came back and one was in a Nazi
camp one was shot down in Germany and
played a deaf-mute for weeks to the
French underground got him yeah man it's
it's something heavy and but he pulled a
chief from Cuckoo's Nest that's right
yes that's exactly right and he they all
came back and he never he never and then
the more I learned that history and just
a guy that never complained always did
the right thing getting up at 5:30 and
walking the [ __ ] sanitation to
collect garbage and you know it's um I
learned a lot from watching that grown
up and I went you know he would always
said sure I got more to me and I went
damn fine I already have 10 times more
and I wanted my kids to have uh it's all
about walk the walk man walk the walk
and I there was a time where I would do
it and I'd feel I feel jealous envious
like little these guys should be God
maybe I was and but you know what I
wouldn't trade any of it in for the
world so I I can sleep really good at
night so uh it's just you know I felt
like that's the thing to do and it was
easy for you to do it easy it was so
easy I enjoyed having them around
it really did so that definitely helped
you know he was funniest [ __ ] in a road
yeah but when you night you're not you
don't have them in your life is like a
big void or is it just kind of it fills
up with other stuff well I say this the
my dad is the more of the big like if I
think of my dad I instantly get a hole
in me when I feel bad and it lasted over
over a year and change and I would have
serious primal crying breakdowns serious
just where they were they out of nowhere
or did anything like bring them on like
would it be like I saw this yeah mercial
and oh my god that's like me and my dad
that happens when I'm coming
[Laughter]
a little bit of both a little bit of
both sometimes it'll just be out of
nowhere somebody I brought him a lot on
the road so I would I would you know I'd
see a place or whatever and I'd hear
something he'd say and then boom like
you try to avoid it and that night
you're in the hotel room you're alone
you know boom the emotions kick in and
when you start crying you just like you
know what I'm gonna get primal with this
I'm gonna let everything out because I'm
I can't I can't hold it back anymore the
dam is broken yeah oh I go full primal I
don't you [ __ ] yeah I'm my eyes get all
[ __ ] me in the other room same noise
depressed which one is doing what that's
a game show guess what the Jimmy's are
doing do you cry in front of people like
will you let your wife see that or are
you embarrassed [ __ ] yeah well you'll
get over embarrassment a long time ago
if I tell story my eye starts swelling
up I won't primal infrastructure but
kids will see you cry oh hell yeah yeah
absolutely because again you know I feel
like I learned years ago where walk the
walk my kids shouldn't know what it's
like to feel pain and see pain like that
once in a while like [ __ ] dad guys oh
[ __ ] dumb boner is crying here's a song
that way crying and it's a Metallica
song so I don't mind I don't mind them
seeing my emotions right I try to
protect but sometimes I can't protect my
emotions but I have no problem hiding it
from that I want them to know you want
to took care of my dad they all had
different reactions the oldest one was
just I'm out of here
the middle one was just
she was a little freaked out she would
watch my fart the youngest one was hands
on if I was in there with my dad she was
in there my dad and she was look I was
playing my dad she would play my dad all
the way up until his death when when it
was down to the last two minutes she was
in the room playing songs with humps and
I went hunting you don't have to say and
it's ugly at the end it is it's ugly it
they breathe funny it sounds like you
choking to death
and I said you're not this thing I want
to be here dad I want to be here and
then about a year later this is this was
a sick moment it was a year later my
wife's going to her second round of
cancer and she's she got the same hair
as you at the time the [ __ ] bald she
looks like an alien a port thing and I
got a little place upstate New York and
I wasn't into I'm not into anniversary
Jude my dad passed so I was upstate New
York and it was the end of nice with my
friend I grew up with and he goes he
goes let's hang out today and my
daughter goes done neither
I need someone's phone I said no go to
bed I'm hanging out when you and your
best friend over you like you want to
hang yeah we have a fire and just
confining him she was dad I really want
to find just I need a fun so we need a
phone for I can't tell you well then you
can't have it so she's doing this with
everyone the family her sisters I said
don't give her the phone she's go to bed
it's like 10:00 10:30 night she goes bed
about 1:00 in the morning I go to bed I
go to check and she wrote oh she wrote a
text about a year ago today grandpa
passed away if you look up the stars and
I hope he's drink beer and watching you
as a son above you're the greatest dad
moments like that yes for me are better
than selling out the [ __ ] garden
financially No
yeah financially it doesn't have the
same but those are powerful those are
powerful moments where you go wow that
that's that's what I won out of and
hopefully she'll do that when she gets
older for someone I don't know how come
it had to be via text because I don't
know that's a good question
because maybe she knew I was gonna read
it and then it sticks forever rather
than just tell me why I'm hanging out my
friend my best friend if she told me
that right there
she doesn't how to communicate with her
mouth so she it's easier in front of me
you know go to bed pee
can you bring it up ten o'clock don't
[ __ ] talk to Larry here by the aliens
Larry I got apologize sorry Larry's kids
Istanbul night you gotta take control
them you gotta take control them a bunch
of animals I want to stay up to 3:00 in
the morning talking about nothing this
[ __ ] about Kidz Bop tickets go to bed
give a [ __ ] what you have to say does
she want to take you to show that you
don't want to go to I just love that you
think it's about kids Bob text and it's
like the sweetest most touching thing oh
my god Harry Stein's I get it I get it
one direction like oh my god so yeah
it's yeah man the wizard and that's all
resonated
from me for what my dad did for me and
you know how's your wife doing she is uh
for the time being doing okay she is she
was diagnosed in February with terminal
it metastasized to the cancer
metastasized to her liver lung bone
Janice yeah yeah that was a heavy that
was a heavy couple months trying to
figure that out so for the time being
she is in a trial and I sinned so she
goes a trial and for the time being the
trial is working so work okay five
months it works it's not doom and gloom
which is another you know I guess some
people go doom and gloom we never were a
doom and gloom family I never was a doom
and gloom guy she looks hot she feels
hot she doesn't you would never know it
looking at her and it's funny she at
first she didn't want to tell she didn't
even want to tell her mom she didn't
want to tell a lot of people because the
first thing you get are letters we're
all praying if it's everybody thinking
they have to come visit even though
they're right in like 20 years we
brought you the best banana nut cake
this is like a really ancient recipe and
we want you to have it sorry just trying
to live my life I just yeah now we're
still good yeah she's ready religious
the prayers not mean anything or she
kind of moved away from that a little
bit no no and I don't she's she believes
she's got deep faith she definitely has
that and she's not one of those you know
there's a weird thing with religion
where people go oh how could God have
such as how could God have a child just
be killed and you've had cancer and
you're the crane that's not God [ __ ] I
don't know what people have in their
heads it's like we're human and whatever
you're into you're into she
she's all about like hey man whatever
this journey is it's kicked ass until
now look at all that we've done and if
this is the way it's gonna go down this
is the way it goes down if I'm not gonna
gloom it and doom it if if anything
every step to has made our visions on
life a lot more clear and crisp and you
have this whole different agenda and you
realize what's really important in life
in general because we're all on borrowed
time at the end the day none of us again
out of here so she's pretty powerful
with her faith man when you found out in
February do you go with her to the
appointment or is it oh yeah and did you
kind of know or were you not sure do you
guys sense that this is what they were
gonna say do you have no idea no I
I knew she still had so she first the
way I found out it was I was right it
was right before I played the Paramount
was like it was February like 12th or
11th last year and I went there and soon
as I came home the next day was right
before Valentine's Day
and I said what I seen the cow who's
this doctor that you've been she didn't
want to tell me and then there were I
said what are what is this doctor and
she went I have something to tell you
when Oh Shh I knew right away like what
you know we've been through it twice
what is it now
and she goes they found tumors
it could be scar tissue it could be I
just said yeah no this is hands down I
know exactly what this I was aware they
find them it's like on my there's some
spots on my on my lung breast this to
her or did you keep it to yourself like
the feeling of dread uh no you don't you
don't put that out there you immediately
go let's see what it is let's wait for
the official word but you could tell by
her doctor at the time he was
very optimistic in ours I put I call
them up say listen what's the deal man
would it what are we looking at here
what do you release a guy you know for
years I can keep her alive there's some
great pills and let's wait for the
biopsy but I'm pretty sure I know what
it is and you know the biopsy came back
and they said it's cancer but now by the
time we hit it was a long brutal process
because when it first happens okay
well now what what what now what and
then you get tested more and the bite
and then they go and then you go to the
real specialists and they go yeah and
they they have to be very you know they
she was a young girl she look like she
was 20 she's like 27 she's like you know
they metastasized and they're in your
liver and lung and basically you're
[ __ ] maybe you'll make it to Christmas
we're not sure but them you know it's up
to you what what we can put you on a
trial and here's what so as you're and I
remember I cracked a joke she said
there's drugs to give you to help you
and I went are there any drugs for me
and my wife cracked up and this woman
was as she looked at me like you and you
one try she didn't understand just read
about you right and that was a heavy
ride home your your whole life your
whole you know I've been with her for 27
28 years right you know we're married 25
this year and you just your whole life
starts flashing and you're it's just you
going he's thinking the kids like okay
okay I'm gonna wha all right ya know
well we'll get through this process and
I'll be alright I'll be I have to be
alright this is the next step in life
this is what it is you know this is life
man here we go
and she's apologized and I
cracking up going don't be sorry but you
know I wish I knew your genetic pole
before we jumped into this I'm gonna
tell others for you married check into
their gene pool and once they're [ __ ]
history and just cracking jokes laughing
and then once she had a she we started
checking out all hospitals across the
world and all that for trials and thank
God I got a great friend that I grew up
with literally grew up on the same
street with that I've known forever and
he called he called and he always said
he's like Jimmy if you ever you let me
know though ideas you know let me know I
can I can really help and I called my
like hey here's we're at he's sent me
the papers and give me twenty minutes
any colleagues like you need to get her
on a flight tomorrow to Houston Texas so
ok food Houston and the doctors like
how'd you get in here Clark and forty
year waiting and the doctors like you
need to be in Philadelphia right now
right now you are a huge candidate you
are the you are the world's guinea pig
for this price now get on the plane head
to Philadelphia and we said oh we were
in Philadelphia and he goes why didn't
you go on the trial saying well you know
I didn't want to all the side effects
she's like he goes look at Tylenol
there's more side effect they have to
tell you that sure because or your
option is death
pick it it's up to you I mean I'm not
your life and so that's the way we've
been now the first thing they tell you
is I once you go on the trial normally
the first month you take you take a
biopsy they gotta take a biopsy every
month it'll say the tumors are shrinking
don't get excited it's the second third
month where you find out where this is
it working did spread of the tumors
getting big you have less time or is
this kind of working and she didn't hear
that I recorded every
thing and I go in a doctor's office I
recalled oh absolutely smart and then
this way I'd I would go on a plane and I
would listen to this over and over and
I'm home back tears and well you're
doing it for information absolutely
so she I was in I was in Atlanta Georgia
and I got a FaceTime from her and she
was crying thinking back in the tumors
shrunk and she told friends if people
call me at least accredit but I wasn't
even remembered I was tormented because
I didn't want to crush her joy sure but
I knew in the back of my in the back of
my mind in my heart I went we're really
not gonna know [ __ ] for at least another
month so so but I had and then the
second month came and I was holding my
breath was right okay here we go
and they're like yeah it's amazing still
working so now we're up to five months
and now the doctors and all them are
super excited and pharmaceuticals
excited but you know what man there's no
I don't know how attorneys just kid we
live month a month a month a month we go
hey just get another kick-ass month we
got another kick-ass so all the way back
to a shameless plug
no but in seriousness being able to do
something like this knowing I'm home
right oh yeah once a month and if it
turns into something and I don't have to
travel that much it's you know it's uh
it's definitely all a good thing the
whole day and Jim is such a hilarious
comedian it's the Jim Breuer residency
at the Paramount official Jim Breuer
calm and it's at Dell in Parramatta in
Long Island and money yeah that's good
the first three shows by the way are
February 17th March 3rd and April 14th
tickets will go on sale this Friday at
10:00 a.m.
pre-sale is Wednesday at 10:00 a.m. for
Paramount fan club members and city card
holders hey hey but I'm amazed that you
you got all three shows if you can why
not they probably all gonna be different
they are everyone is different
even knock on wood not saying there's a
guarantee but if I go past the three
months sure I'm prepared for at least a
year's worth you are Oh hands down hands
down I haven't put out a special awhile
and I've been gathering tight tight
material back pockets storytelling in
these little [ __ ] holes in middle of
nowhere I don't come the city forum and
with the band we did I'm pretty I'm
pretty exciting out I know I got
production and everything else I'm
really hot why didn't you ever do like a
one-man show all these comedians do
these one-man shows in Montreal and
they're and they're good or like but but
you're such an amazing storyteller it
probably better than most you till you
encouraged me to do that a while ago and
I never forgot that
and I I always try to figure out an
angle and I honestly am starting one I
started toying with it last year and now
I'm working on it in January February
and March are you able to go back like
when I if I'm writing something it has
to be in the moment like the emotions in
the moment I have to grab it or I lose
it
are you able to go back and grab stuff
like this is how I felt six months ago
and make it relevant yes that's exactly
what's happening to me now because at
the time and then and then you lose the
momentum right the momentum right so now
that I'm I'm going back and looking at
these things where oh god I forgot this
story in this moment in time and is this
part of my life and boom and and then I
get all hopped up and excited again it's
amazing me someone who's a good story
I'm a horrendous storyteller terrible
because you lose focus right I don't
know what it is I'm all over the place I
lose focus
I have zero faith in the destination and
the journey there's confidence telling a
story before I start I'm like that with
the jokes I'm the same way but with
jokes he talks of hilarious though and
there's spruce all over the your store
he would tell you would close we did the
anti-social toward me
Jim did it Stanhope did it tell Amy
there's a whole bunch of comedians you
already yeah you were always hilarious
and you would close the story about your
dad and hosing down the dry it was
[ __ ] hilarious hilarious that was a
great great great tour man we had a lot
there's that was some belly laugh and oh
yeah oh my god
Adele I remember sitting on the side
watching to tell in Washington DC and he
did a whole thing about the hotel he was
at and playing with a donkey with
whatever they had they had all the
different presidents on it I did that's
some of the hardest ever laughs in my
life
yeah that was a really fun who went to
the Pentagon it was who I was me you
Bill and Dave right went to the Pentagon
yes and I got a world war two had from
my dad he did yeah I remember that we
were seeing like wounded warriors yes I
remember that we went downstairs I'm
like sitting with them and talking with
them and yeah that was heavy I tell is
really good with with I didn't you know
you talk to soldiers but you almost feel
like I I don't qualify to speak to these
men name because like what do I say to
these guys that's it I have nothing to
offer them but it tell was great Wow let
me see your scar and they were all they
loved it they would he just talked to
them like the old regular dudes I tell
is really really good with those guys he
was he was really good with that you're
right cuz I feel the same with you I
don't know like so yeah I'm working on
this bit like yeah we're going to Disney
we're all the family so yeah sucks to be
you uh you know I don't know what to say
but you're right Dave would you know let
me see what you got going on there like
Wow almost there not socks
yeah asking real questions where'd that
happen what happened no one Minds
telling you their experiences especially
guys for more stories exactly you know a
bloke has leg blown off he probably
loved to tell you where it happened
right he wants a regular conversation
rather than the whole like I feel so bad
for you you know or trying to relate
like I understand how you feel you know
you don't just told me right no you
don't matter at all you have no relative
experience but I know I'm too aware of
the fact that I can only guess at what
it feels like I'm too aware of it yeah
and so I just panic him don't tell I'm
sort of the same way as you
my grandfather's doing he's been trying
to steal valour I think oh no I'm
walking around telling people is this
legit but uh
he's not joking he's not he's this is
not he's not joking like he was asking
one of my aunts why he doesn't get more
she sees Howard Stern's grandfather he's
trying to ask why he doesn't get more
respect because he fought in three was
be fought in three was active in three
wars he said wow she was like pop you
weren't active in three wars he was like
yes I was and she was like what and he
was like wow World War two I was active
and like even my mom like that's the one
that might be but my mom was like he
didn't fight in World War two that would
have been his generation but he was
active maybe but not and then he goes
and he goes Korean War and we're they
were like William do you want in the
Korean War at all and then he and
illegitimate
batting an eye on without joking he goes
in the cold war they were like what you
know he's trying he's trying to get
credit for fighting in the cold war can
I tell you that I don't want to say it
was but a person I love to death right
now
I didn't know I don't know I always
thought the term veteran I'm a veteran
meant you were in battle right sure okay
that that's just what I naturally think
like oh I'm a veteran of oh whoa you
were in battle okay so I'm with this
great person I love older guy he's got a
half million million pins and all that
and one of them says veteran I know for
a fact you know they were in the service
but you gonna fight never ever
not even close Soviet so we we get an
elevator and this woman gets in she goes
oh thank you for your service you're a
veteran and he goes yes I am and I went
I just turned and she goes where what
war were you in no way this is gonna be
a great answer cuz I know for a fact you
haven't been anything and I'm gonna hold
you real accountable considering my dad
was in World War two let's let's see
where we going with this and he went I
was active during the Cuban Missile
Crisis I was just signing up
oh no no so I don't know if it's to get
free donuts on Tuesday when the legions
all get together and eat I don't but my
grandfather's just a scumbag so he's
just trying to he's trying to get
whatever credit ich so yeah but your
friend coulda just said no no I was
never in battle I was in the military
yeah and I answer to give but he wants
the credits offshore because he knows
that even if even if technically veteran
means that you could be just in the
military he knows that the respect is to
soldiers who served in battle which is
where it should be right
exhaust that he wants to be wrong I was
at the PX the base I was down in
Monmouth at the base loops were for cost
other men gave their limbs nobody wants
to say that that was the [ __ ] PX
taking the discount that those men
earned me by losing an arm cost if you
can get IV get a pin that just said the
word hero on it instead of veteran you
go with hero you're absolutely right
you're right and I really think it's
just for the free donuts but it's gotta
be tempting to and we have to wrap up
and like what a minute Travis one minute
it's got to be tempting when you see
other guys getting such respect and you
know that you didn't avoid war you just
didn't go to what you were in the
military got to like [ __ ] I would a guy
missed the glory forgetting you have to
go through the battle uh my mom wouldn't
let me yes I have one bad eye
I was dying at him it's legit it's
really bad even though it was a why just
happy to go to Toronto for four years